keep
get down a society with a foggy past and
an uncertain future is one that is truly
lost and such is the reality for the
denizens of the world of horizon zero
dawn roughly one thousand years from
today tribal communities lead primitive
lives surrounded by mysterious high-tech
fossils of the old ones the fractured
legacy of our real actual world the
results of technological advancement run
amok
small animals like rabbits and borscht
still roam the while but they trot in
the footsteps of imposing mechanical
beasts that dominantly strive through
dense jungle and lurk on snowy mountain
how the world ended up in disarray isn't
clear at first but a Loy an orphan
outcast who locates an advanced
communications and analysis device holds
the key to unlocking these mysteries
using your newfound tool known as a
focus you can tap into techno artifacts
and glean info about the past well the
full story of the world's downfall takes
a while to unravel the fascinating
revelations you uncover more than make
up for time spent navigating less than
compelling tribal politics during the
first half of the game find your pet
outcast Andrey was winning the proving
that's the closest you're going to get
and thankfully no matter where the story
takes you Kombat deservedly owns the
spotlight the world's intricately
crafted environments teem with electric
beasts and warfare and coltan and the
pronounced excitement of controlling a
Roy in the midst of rampaging enemy is a
near constant thrill this excitement
comes in part due to a low his ability
to definitely leap out of harm's way and
bound right back into action but her
arsenal of weapons and ammunition are
the special ingredients that give you
the ability to topple zero Dawn's
massive robotic monsters you start with
a simple bone arrow but you eventually
gain access to elementally charge bolt
when shots that lob explosives and in a
servant of traps that can surprise or
constrict unsuspecting enemy dodged
rolling between enemies turning around
and jumping to deliver a critical blow
while drawing and aiming your bones
flowmotion
never gets old and zero dome
there are no actual supernatural powers
on display unless you count the fact
that yellows focus can pinpoint enemy
weak points but nevertheless when the
controls seep in your subconscious
heroic displays of cunning light and
fearlessness lend alloy at superhuman
quality unfortunately mainly combat is
far less effective your only options are
to issue a light or heavy spear attack
and was fighting indoors you're more
likely to hit a wall than your intended
target
but thanks for your never forced to use
Mainland and can always revert to
fighting with a mix of evasive maneuvers
and projectile weapons where you face
small bipedal washers and approximations
of horses and bowls at the start you
eventually engage in rampaging armored
crocodiles Jaguar like BOTS with
cloaking devices and yes giant enemy
craft by the end of the game you can
confidently roll into battle facing a
towering metallic t-rex
knowing full well that you are in
control despite your relatively
diminutive stature
a well-placed shot on a body part that
glows three lights focus can knock off a
piece of armor and exclude a robot's
vulnerable energy
it's also possible to disarm enemies and
use their own weapons against them your
standard weapons are effective enough
but nothing beats picking up and firing
a massive laser cannon as a result of
tactful aggression to finish off the
fight
for combat is at the forefront of zero
dawn you also have bitterly gather any
resource and reaches you travel from
point A to point B plans and pieces of
animals and robots alike are necessary
for crafting a Lloyd's ammunition and
traps upgrading item storage and brewing
health potion when it comes to making
items it's as simple as looking through
a crafting menu and seeing what is or
isn't available based on your inventory
on the other hand selling items is a
paint as there's no way to sort your
inventory at a store for a game that
manages to handle complex systems in
real time with a plum it's odd to see
something as basic as inventory
management fall by the wayside as you
trek across euro Dawn's map you'll run
into tribes and communities most are
modest just a few shacks but a handful
of miniature kingdoms offer sizable
populations of merchants and quest
givers at best typical side quests are
vehicles that propel you into the
far-reaching wild with some semblance of
narrative motivation but it's common to
find a personality behind the mission
far more interesting than the ultimate
meaning of your objective I wasn't
judging you I wasn't a catalyst with
larger questions and destinies at play
in the main quest zero dawn sub stories
simply can't compete on a more positive
note you eventually come across
alien-like constructs in the open world
and at the heart of each of these
intricate otherworldly dungeons is a
machine that will give you the power to
hack robotic animals some robots will
simply fight on your side or leave you
alone when hacked but if you allow you
to ride on their back granted this
option is limited no you cannot ride a
giant robot t-rex but it's the one
argument for the game stealth mechanics
as you can only hack a robot by sneaking
up to it without being noticed the
dueling themes of nature and technology
and 0 Dawn's open world are also
embodied by a loin her life begins as a
member I'll be an outcast of an
isolationist tribe but she's forever
changed when she accepts technology into
her life her focus device is the source
of not only her abilities but her
connection to the world and its past
her past Eloy transforms in so many ways
throughout her Odyssey and it's amazing
to look back when it's all said and done
reflecting on not just the challenges
you've overcome but also on how much
confidence and maturity a boy's gained
in the process 0 dawn is the first
departure from the Killzone series for
developer guerrilla game and though you
might think the team took a risk by
stepping out of this FPS comfort zone to
create a third-person open-world action
game you'd never know it was their first
rodeo for every minor letdown there's an
element of greatness that recharges your
desire to
fighting and exploring guerrilla games
has delivered one of the best open-world
games of this generation and redefined
his team's reputation in the process
you